okay let's go next to our caller from
the seven nine four seven nine area code
who's calling today from four seven nine
hello david my name is Jacob I'm from
Fort Smith Arkansas how you doing today
hey how you doing Jacob I'm doing all
right
so I called you a couple years ago and
I'm wondering if your ashes this is a
question and I'm just wondering if you
you probably may not remember the
question but like I'm wondering if
you'll probably have evolved on this
question that I'm gonna ask you
basically I asked you about Medicare for
all right and if you think it ever be
implemented but you know with Bernie
Sanders running this campaign the way he
does and let's say he does win and the
way he plans on trying to get
implemented do you think it's more
likely now do you think you have evolved
on if he wins that you know in the next
5-10 years we could actually have like a
medic Medicare for All system or do you
think it's still because you said before
back when I talked to you it was like a
state-by-state issue that you probably
think is more likely but like with way
Bernie Sanders is tried that rally his
people that his constituent
the Democratic base I mean I'm just
thinking it's more likely he could
possibly get it implemented but I don't
know what yeah I mean I definitely think
it's I think that now my perspective is
that it's more likely that there will be
a national Medicare for all
implementation than I thought whenever
you call a couple of years ago I still
think that there are just significant
barriers and I think that the idea of
doing it at the state level still at
least initially doing state single-payer
is still not a bad idea particularly
because the states most likely to first
implement it are the states where the
math will be most favorable to actually
doing it but I've actually the way I've
evolved is a different one on Medicare
for all I am more open than ever to
other ways of achieving universal
coverage in a non-profit non-predatory
way and this has become a reality for me
just by learning more about other
systems whether it's the German system
French or UK Canada etc so I'm a huge
supporter of expanding Medicare
medicare-for-all it would be multiple
times better than what we have but I
also and I said this on the Joe Rogan
program and it was misquoted
interestingly um Medicare as a base has
some issues of course they are solvable
issues so my position is I'm open to any
path that takes the vulture capitalism
out of health care and it makes sure
that everybody has access to care
regardless of ability to pay I will have
a conversation about any of those
systems and I think Medicare for all is
a good option but it's just one option
yes I agree with you there because like
with people that are not able to afford
it I mean it just makes sense that you
know when you need help you should be
able to get it without having to you
know break the bank you know I mean any
type of I think Medicare for all would
be good and you know because they're
always going to be rich people and poor
people no matter what kind of especially
living in a capitalist society there's
always going to be somebody at the
bottom of the ladder that they're gonna
need help if it's that people get sick
so I do agree with you so all right very
good appreciate the call you're out
audio sounding a bit odd so I'm gonna
let you go but yes my view if it has
evolved it has evolved only in being
more optimistic for sure